stacey abrams is one of the country's
best-known voting rights advocates and
she's also a prolific
author in her new thriller while justice
sleeps a supreme court clerk has to
unravel an
international conspiracy that goes to
the highest levels of government
and stacey abrams joins us now stacy
good morning to you
uh allow me to be the first person to
read you a great new york times review
here that ends
abrams has realized what surely was her
chief ambition
to entertain that's good news and we
want to get to the book
but first while we have you uh there are
some twists and turns in our world as we
live it uh that i want you to comment on
if you could
there are about 11 states right now in
the country that have passed
restrictions on
voting that could have a big impact on
2022 and beyond
what concerns you most about what you're
seeing right now
that rather than this bringing every
american to
attention and raising their concerns
this is being treated as a partisan
exercise unfortunately this is
republicans who are stripping
access to the right to vote from all
americans and it is a danger to our
democracy
this is not about who wins an election
it's about whether we have elections
that are free and fair and unfortunately
in these states we are seeing
a response to free and fair elections by
trying to
strip away and restrict access
particularly for communities of color
young people and the disabled and that
is deeply problematic and should be of
concern to everyone so there is the
issue of how it affects uh
trust in our elections uh in the the act
of democracy
itself and yet there's also the
practical political implication
what does this mean do you think for
2022 for democrats chances
again i i certainly recognize that i
enter this conversation as someone who
is a very strong allegiance
to the democratic party but what is so
important is that we not relegate this
and and be so reductive that we think
about this
as a purely political issue because the
reality is no matter what the intent
the undermining of our democracy is a
danger to everyone regardless of their
party
and that's why it's so urgent that we
stop treating this as a binary
conversation
between democrats and republicans and
really focus on this as an issue of
citizenship versus partisanship yeah the
senate will begin
debate today on a very interesting bill
it's called the for the people act and
it would create
federal standards for voting access
some minimums for providing access to
the ballot box
doesn't seem to have a chance uh but
what do you see
is there a path forward for this bill i
think the more we watch these states
undertake the continuation of what the
insurrectionists began on january 6th
the more likely we are to see real
response at the federal level
this is not the first time the federal
government has had to step in and
reassert the fundamental notions of who
we are as a nation
and my hope is that while this process
continues in the u.s senate
that we see a return to just the
fundamentals we've got former
secretaries of state former governors
who are sitting in that body now who
understand how important it is to
protect the right to vote
for every american stacey abrams you're
known for
writing your romance novels like hidden
sins
secrets and lies deception
never tell the art of desire and they're
written under the name
did you like that reading stacy written
under the name of selena montgomery but
for the first time i'm holding up the
book you've written a book under your
own name while justice sleeps
and boy do you take us on a ride it
involves a corrupt president
who's ruthless a just a justice of the
supreme court who's in a coma
a law clerk a biotech company it's it is
so complex and so wild and boy
what a ride why did you decide to put
your name on this one
the only reason my name wasn't on selena
montgomery's novels is that i was
writing tax articles and social policy
treatises
at the same time i began publishing in
fiction and it was much easier to keep
them separate it was less about hiding
that i wrote romance and being more
concerned about romance readers not
wanting to read romance by a tax
wonk but but avery keene as you point
out or she says
i'm not just a law kirk tell us about
her a law clerk
so avery is this incredibly complicated
young woman who is
finishing her second year as a law clerk
to a supreme court justice
and who's just trying to figure out what
she's going to do next she's got to deal
with a
strange relationship with her mother and
really uncertain future
and she gets dragged into the story
where she has to
execute this power of attorney this
responsibility for a supreme court
justice
but without really having the authority
to make anyone do what she needs them to
do
and she's got to stay alive while she
tries to do it yeah mom's got some drug
issues i thought it was interesting to
hear that your family was involved in
this
number one i think it's cool that your
family has its own book club i think
that's really nice
but your family was involved in writing
this one or not writing it but they were
giving you
input well i've been privileged to have
my siblings help me with most of my
books my dad actually
on one of my romance novels had some
very arcane knowledge i needed to use at
some point
but in this book it was really my
brothers and sisters who each pitched in
as i was writing to save me a lot of
time on google because it's easier we
can go to
you know a first source who can tell you
exactly what you need to know
stacy we had jake tapper on yesterday
another very busy person who somehow
found
time to write a book he said he did it
because he set aside 15 minutes a day
at least to write how do you do it
i i i'm not that disciplined in that way
but what i do figure out is how many
days it will take me to write i can
write between
2 500 and 3 000 words a day and so i
carve out a number of days necessary to
give myself time to write time to hate
writing
time to come back and get it done anyway
and it is
usually because i've figured out the
other parts of my week
but i love writing and i'm going to get
it done stacy i love this sunday morning
piece that you did
the other day i really loved the end
they were talking about dating and you
said you had a relationship didn't work
out because of your schedule
but you said something that really
resonated with me you said it's really
nice to have somebody like you
it's really nice to have somebody who
likes you and i think that that is so
true
because let me tell you the struggle is
real it's hard out here for pimp
so what are you thinking about when it
comes to dating stacey abrams in your
life you got a lot of stuff going on
well i i have not focused on it that
much this month
we've been trying to work on democracy
and you know
preserving access for you know americans
and fighting to make sure covet recovery
is real
but if the guy realizes i'm out here and
wants to you know drop me a note i'm
looking forward to meeting him
all right i have a i have a buffy the
vampire slayer question
but we have to go to comedy do we oh go
ahead all right i'm gonna as a non-fan
i'm gonna read this one right off the
page here you are a huge buffy the
vampire
slayer fan actors have come forward in
recent months alleging mistreatment by
the creator
josh joss whedon can you separate the
art from the man
i think it's important in all art forms
to recognize that the product
sometimes is different in fact
often is different than the creator
there are and i talked about this in
another piece that i i responded to
stacy we got to go to we got to go we'll
pick it up on the internet one second uh
the book while justice sleeps is out
today we'll be right back